also some news this morning out of North
Korea because North Korea is greeting
the start of the South Korea's Winter
Olympics by showing off its military
might
soldiers paraded with tanks
intercontinental ballistic missiles and
other weapons in North Korea's capital
Pyongyang this morning in front of
direct of dictator Kim jong-un a few
hours later Vice President Mike Pence
arrived in Seoul to meet with South
Korean president moon jae-in he repeated
president Trump's call for North Korea
to give up its nuclear weapons Ventre
seized up the games in Pyeongchang with
a message behind North Korea's display
been good morning good morning so North
Korea really has dominated the run-up to
these games first by just deciding to
come then by sending a 550 person
delegation and now by staging this
massive military parade on the eve of
the opening ceremony North Korea put on
a major show of force for the 70th
anniversary of the founding of its army
tens of thousands of soldiers marched in
kim il-sung's square it also proudly
paraded many of its weapons of war
including two different versions of its
intercontinental ballistic missiles
believed to be capable of striking the
United States Kim jong-un and his
generals looked on from above
that's probably North Korea's way of
trying to show that it is relevant that
it can control the narrative in the
region shake cotton is an expert on
North Korea's weapons program he says if
kim giman was trying to look more
rational by engaging with South Korea
over the Olympics this was an odd way to
show it
I think if North Korea wanted to be
reasonable with something like this they
wouldn't be holding a parade the day
before the Olympics anyways
during Vice President Mike Pence's visit
to Japan he told hundreds of US military
personnel at Yokota Air Base that
military action against North Korea he
is possible those who dare threaten us
would do well not to underestimate the
capabilities of the Armed Forces of the
United States North Korea was officially
welcomed at the Olympic athletes village
today and South Korean president
in plans to host members of the Norse
delegation including the sister of Kim
jong-eun for lunch this weekend
meanwhile American luge athlete Erin
Hamlin who was named Team USA's flag
bearer is excited about the North Korean
athletes who are participating in the
games and that's what it's all about is
bringing people together in a peaceful
environment to celebrate sport and
something that we all love to do for the
most part the athletes don't seem to be
focused on all the politics that are
surrounding these Olympic Games and
Olympic competition has now officially
begun today the American curling duo of
Matt and Becca Hamilton they are brother
and sister they trounced the Russians
nine to three in their opening match so
while the politics may continue here in
Pyeongchang let the games begin
Jon Ben Tracy in South Korea